[Music]
before we get started i just want to
mention we're almost at 400 000
subscribers so please subscribe if you
haven't already hey everyone welcome to
another installment of harry potter
theory in today's video we're going to
be discussing what harry's life would
have been like if he'd been raised by
his godfather sirius black but before we
dive into how very different harry's
life would have been let's first discuss
how this scenario could have come to
pass
our dear boy harry was bitten orphan at
the mere age of 1 on the 31st of october
in 1981 when lily and james potter were
murdered by voldemort at the potter
family cottage in godric's hollow the
young family's whereabouts were supposed
to have been concealed by the fidelius
charm with only their chosen secret
keeper knowing their exact location as
most of you will know it was believed
that sirius james best friend was the
potter's secret keeper
we obviously know this to be incorrect
however as sirius convinced james and
lily that he would be too obvious of a
choice and so they changed their minds
at the last minute to peter pettigrew
who of course betrayed them giving up
the potter's whereabouts to voldemort
from there an enraged sirius went after
peter to confront him on the shocking
betrayal of their friend somehow in this
encounter peter or wormtail as he was
also known committed a mass murder
transformed into his animagus form as a
mouse and scurried away leaving a
devastated young sirius to blame for all
of the death and destruction
but what if sirius hadn't gone after
peter pettigrew to exact revenge on
behalf of james and lilly what if he'd
never confronted wormtail been framed
for all those murders gotten caught and
ultimately been sent to azkaban prison
for the next decade instead what if he'd
arrived on the scene at the bottas
cottage in godric's hollow and rather
than leave his bike with hagrid to go
after wormtail he'd been convinced to
stay with his newly orphaned godson
harry had sirius been able to keep his
cool in this moment and not rush off he
could have explained to dumbledore and
the others that he was never the
potter's secret keeper that lily and
james had entrusted peter instead having
convinced a powerful and respected
wizard like dumbledore of the truth the
others in the order likely would have
also accepted sirius's testimony
especially if wormtail had still
committed those other murders you know
the ones he used to fake his own death
when sirius confronted him because of
course if sirius never went to confront
him if he was never there how could he
have been framed with sirius's name
cleared at least in the eyes of the
order the next obvious question would
have been who would raise harry it's
possible that dumbledore still would
have thrown out the dursleys as a
possibility but considering how
unconvinced hagrid and mcgonagall were
about this arrangement when sirius
wasn't an option as guardian it's very
likely that the idea of placing harry in
petunia and vernon's care would have
been shot down pretty quickly leaving
sirius as the obvious choice so sirius a
young man of only 22 would have been
given guardianship of little harry at
least from the perspective of the order
the ministry of magic may not have been
as easily convinced of sirius as
innocence especially if wormtail still
vanished that night
so i'd like to think that the order
would have helped sirius set up a safe
space to raise our boy harry in my
opinion the most likely option would
have been a padfoot's ancestral home at
number 12 grimmell place just as this
location was concealed by another
fidelis charm for the order of the
phoenix later in the series dumbledore
or another wizard could have protected
the home in similar manner for sirius
and tauri so does this mean that harry
would have grown up famous would he have
straight away walked among the witches
and wizards that praised him for what he
was able to accomplish well not really
you see harry would have then had a
sheltered life growing up in a primarily
muggle borough of london due to his
godfather's need to keep a lower profile
harry may not have had quite as many
experiences as other young witches and
wizards however there would have been
several major positive differences in
how he was raised let's take a look
number one first and foremost harry
would have been brought up in a loving
home compared to the emotional and
physical abuse that harry sustained in
the dursley's care i mean he literally
grew up in a cupboard under the stairs
at number four privet drive harry would
have grown up feeling loved and cared
for this would have amplified his
already compassionate nature and made
him more confident upon entering his
first year at hogwarts number two next
on the list and it's a big one being
raised by sirius would mean that harry
knew he was a wizard he would have known
who he was who voldemort was and what
had actually happened to his parents
that terrible night he would know where
the scar on his head came from he
wouldn't be confused by the magical
happenings that would later occur as he
approached the age of eleven he would
have known what his parents looked like
watching them move about in magical
photos as his godfather told him what
they've been like before they died
giving harry a much better sense of self
as he matured into a young man which
brings us to our next point number three
if sirius had raised harry and harry had
known about the wizarding world and not
being confined to the dursley's cupboard
he likely would have developed a lot
more personal relationships quite
obviously this would have started with
sirius as a father figure but there
would have been many more caring people
involved in harry's life as well
dumbledore may have checked in from time
to time of course remus lupin member of
the marauders james and sirius's good
friend would have been around he may
have even helped raise harry in a sense
being the more level-headed of the two
friends harry also would have been
introduced to other young witches and
wizards he may have even met the weasley
children before attending hogwarts
through ties of the order number four
harry would have learned to fly a
broomstick at a very young age as some
of you may know sirius actually gave
harry his very first broomstick for
christmas at the tender age of one with
sirius raising little harry their joint
enthusiasm for flying serious on his
motorbike and harry on a broomstick
would have just been one more thing that
bonded the two together as an
enthusiastic flyer harry would have
become a fan of quidditch as soon as he
was introduced to the sport which of
course would have been in early
childhood once again his experiences
within the wizarding world would impact
his confidence once at hogwarts he still
would have been selected as the
gryffindor team seeker but he would have
made the team by attending tryouts
instead of being accidentally recruited
by mcgonagall in year one maybe harry
would have even gone to join
professional quidditch team number five
now this next one may be more than a
little contentious to say but since
sirius was portrayed as a fairly cool
character it's not that far-fetched to
imagine that if harry had grown up with
him as his guardian harry may have been
a little less
nerdy i'm not talking about anything
that would have changed his personality
but perhaps he would have worn glasses
that were a bit more trendy or he could
have taken to contacts
sirius could have also taught him how to
style his untidy hair and when harry's
interesting girls began old pantford
would have been there to help him know
how to approach the ladies respectfully
of course not that harry did too badly
for himself in this area but certain
interactions with cho chang or
eventually ginny may have been a little
less awkward number six the sixth and
final difference i'll mention although
there could arguably be many more is
that if harry had been raised by sirius
he likely would have been told all about
the mischief that his father and
godfather caught up to as students harry
may even have fallen asleep as a young
boy listening to sirius regale him with
stories of the marauder's adventures
learning why they formed the group to
help bloop in with his monthly
transformations as a werewolf harry then
would have discovered how james and
sirius taught themselves to be anime guy
transforming into animals and back again
into humans at will he would know all
about james's form as a stag which is
why they called him prongs and series
his form as a dog leading to his
nickname padfoot this would have perhaps
given harry an intense interest in
learning how to become an animagus
himself i think harry could have even
done it transforming into say a woodland
creature like his father perhaps a fox
or wolf which would have aligned him
with both sirius and james or maybe he
would have also been a stag just like
his patronus was which brings us to the
end of this video what do you guys think
did i miss any obvious differences what
do you think harry's life would have
been like if he'd been raised by sirius
let me know down in the comments below
and don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to the channel if you enjoyed
the content additionally if you want to
hear about another one of these videos
where harry's circumstances lead him
down a darker path then i'd be happy to
make that as well
until next time remember when all this
is over we'll be a proper family you'll
see
[Music]